jennifer aniston takes a look back at
brad pitt's guest appearance on friends
good stuff though the year is 2001.
jen and brad tied the knot a year
earlier in a highly publicized wedding
and brad makes a guest appearance on his
wife's hit
sitcom look at her standing there with
those yams
my two greatest enemies ross rachel
green and complex carbohydrates
yeah remember that well on thursday the
long-awaited friends the reunion special
dropped on hbo max
and the cast took a little stroll down
memory lane recalling all the a-list
celebs they had on the show
julia roberts that's right and who enjoy
julia roberts
come on
yeah julia roberts danny devito ben
stiller and
sean penn just to name a few don't you
give me a kiss
okay i will but right after you have to
tell me who the hell you are
and then we get the script and of course
i realize that i oh i'm a
i'm a potato hey
like very little if any dialogue with
him but
here i'm thinking greatest actor in the
world and i'm a potato
i'm a potato oh my god you're sputnik
yes
and of course there was brad who came on
the show to play a former school friend
of ross's
who hilariously hated jen's character
rachel
with a passion fella right
yes yes pitt came did one rachel and
dream
god i hated ross and while brad and jen
split over 15 years ago
the two have made headlines with their
friendly reunions in recent years
and a source told et this week that they
quote respect each other and think each
other is
wildly talented and hilarious the source
said they've been friends
for quite some time adding quote there's
nothing romantic there but they
are definitely aware that their fans are
constantly rooting for them to get back
together
and laugh about it together what do you
make of all the ridiculousness about
you and brad reuniting on all these
carpets all season long
it's hysterical but what else are they
going to talk about that was jen back in
2020
laughing off all the headlines about her
and her ex and their friendly
interactions during awards season
what do you make of our reaction to the
big reunion backstage last week at the
sag
i don't know i'm blissfully naive and
i'm gonna stay that way
it's something brad's talked to et about
too the world the internet
everyone is waiting they're hoping for
this moment where you and jennifer run
into each other so they can take their
picture
i'll run into jen she's a good friend
yeah yeah so they can
you know you know how this goes the
second the second most
important reunion ever of of her year
exactly you know how that works playing
on friends and then they were saying
that
anyways and while brad was talking about
the friends reunion
over a year ago fans finally got the
show they've been waiting for
we've had a wonderful couple of days
it's been very nostalgic
and uh and really just heartwarming
couple of days
uh being on the set and seeing this
seeing the old set
and uh seeing the crew and seeing the
scene seeing the the old guys and
it's just it's a very loving group
filming was postponed
due to the pandemic but when e.t caught
up with the cast
they said it was worth the wait courtney
how amazing was it actually to be back i
know you guys are friends anyway to be
back in this set on the set with you all
all together kind of
in this zone again it was the most emote
i i i had slept so well the night before
woke up i wasn't nervous at all just
feeling good the first question like
how do you feel i was like and then
started crying and then i walked on the
set and i had no idea
that seeing everything look exactly the
same and these incredible friends that
even though i see
these two a lot i still was just like
jenny are you crying as much as me she's
like yeah
it was just the most emotional thing and
then today she can't stop crying so
it's one of those it wasn't just
courtney you all had that moment
yesterday it was just a real oh yeah and
once her
gates opened then it was i couldn't shut
it off you couldn't even i could plug it
i didn't
no nothing right